Starting with the top red box, it looks like it takes up the entire row and
contains a few elements inside of it.
So, this one's going to be row.
Let's look at the top blue box.
It contains a name and
title, and it looks like it's taking up about half of this whole row.
As a result, I'm going to put column 6.
However, this box could be larger than 6 wide.
Because the text is right aligned, if this box were over here, or
if it expanded over here, it'd still look the same.
So your answer could be larger than column 6, but
it's definitely no larger than column 10.
For the bottom red box, it's taking up the entire row and
it contains some columns inside of it, so, once again we have a row.
And then for the bottom blue box here, it's taking up a third of this row.
A third of twelve is four, so this is going to be column 4.